when i tried to get people to read books
i told you this crazy reaction i got
from one person
which is not representative i started a
book club to try to get my team and i
said it's mandatorily uh
optional it's kind of my joke like i
really wish you would be there but i
can't force you to be there and
you know i would say like of my
important people in my organizations
it's almost 100 percent come at 6 pm on
mondays once a month when i do book club
at this week startups
dot com slack there's a book thing uh
the next book is
i love capitalism and um
the hot hand and previously we did never
split the difference
uh but who's on the clock for this
because there's one person who asked me
to pay them over time
like oh it's just mind-blowing but how
does the law work
how do companies look at it
and then you know how do you think it
should work
yeah um you and i should connect on book
clubs next time so i'm actually the
founder of bookclub.com as well but i
know i saw that
whoa let's make a startup
next time let's make that into a startup
i'll back that yeah all right you
literally on bookclub.com
yeah that's me is it a platform or is it
like a real business or is it just a
hobby a side hustle
no it's it's a venture backed startup oh
okay i missed it
do you want to write a check on the pod
podcast i don't know
what's the business model of
bookclub.com yeah is it just a sense
it's uh author author-led book clubs and
it's a subscription business
fascinating because i did a uh for angel
the book
i just created angel university of
course and the course is free you used
to give a hundred dollars to charity
um all proceeds go to charity but uh
yeah i like this idea of authors doing
the book clubs because you get paid a
certain amount but the course actually
you can charge more for and i think that
was master classes idea
and then other people are doing like
these 500 000 courses which is
incredible
but what a great domain name well done
so back to the question who's on the
clock
for educational legal answer
legal answer first if you're a salaried
employee then you can ask people to
learn on their own time if you're an
hourly employee then yes the the law
states that if you require people to
learn something that you have to pay
them for it which gets
uh complicates this in a lot of ways
okay so the salary which is typically
over 50 or 60 grand depending i think on
the state or is that a federal law but
i think it is yeah i'll tell you because
i i think it's
there's an a big insight at the the back
end of this question
and the journey i've been on was you
know increasingly we're responsible for
our careers if
you know with lifelong learning becoming
the mandate you've just got to be
learning all the time
and if you expect your employer to give
that to you or to require it of you
you know you're going to get left behind
you just you've got to take ownership
of your learning and you've got to be a
great lifelong learner to
to be competitive in today's market but
now
um i've spent years with this question
and sort of watching the journey
and here's what i'd say um you know more
recently
where i've come out on which is we've
seen companies
are giving jp morgan chase committed 350
million dollars to upskilling amazon
committed 700 million dollars to
skilling pwc has a billion dollar
commitment boeing has a billion dollar
commitment
we've seen gigantic upskilling
initiatives from corporations
and yet for all of these big commitments
and programs att did att workforce 2020
which was a gigantic initiative
and they gave zero time which
practically
is just silly because time is actually
the bigger
constraint and barrier in people's lives
rather than um
money in terms of upskilling yep money
is the second
but time is the first yep so why would
you solve your second biggest constraint
be willing to spend hard cash but not be
willing to spend
soft dollars in terms of giving people
time if
if upskilling really matters if it's a
positive roi activity
you should be willing to give you know
soft dollars
in the terms of time if you're willing
to give hard dollars in terms of
of cash um and the the other thing i'll
say here is
that uh wait so when you say that
i it it's still not a perfect answer so
let's say
my goal as the ceo of a company
practically is to get my team
to read six books a year just six books
should i be giving them six days off a
year to read those books is what you're
saying
because it's important or should we
split the difference
or never split the difference so to
speak i think
there's a difference between like
continuous learning which i feel is
more appropriate to to keep that burden
on employees